[Music]
i've always wanted people to see who i
really am the narrative so out of hand
about me and my family there's just no
changing it
we're built for this the kardashian
jenner ladies get real about their lives
in the spotlight i think that you have a
real insight into what the girls are
doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and
that couldn't be more true in the new
teaser for the kardashians season two
i've always wanted people to see who i
really am looks like kim's going to be
baring her soul in the next batch of
episodes while her younger sis kendall
has a strong reaction to the many many
headlines about her famous fan the
narrative so out of hand about me and my
family there's just no changing it
we're built for this there's a lot more
in store in the upcoming season which
premieres september 22nd on hulu in the
official trailer that dropped last month
we caught a glimpse into kris jenner's
hospitalization i don't know what's
happening with you i can't tell my kids
i'm scared they have enough problems
they don't need to worry about mom not
much is known about what happened to
chris but we're expecting to learn more
just tune in because you never know
what's going to happen but on top of
chris's serious storyline the trailer
also teased some lighter moments like
kylie giving birth to her and travis
scott's second child
i made a baby this is my 11th grandchild
i need my first night out i haven't had
a night out in almost a year six months
after he was born baby boy's name is
still under wraps here's hoping kylie
makes the big reveal on the show we have
some baby really strong options but we
haven't officially changed we have some
placeholders so before i officially
change that i just want to be sure and
uh remember this moment babe yeah do you
want to shower with me really quick
yeah we're gonna see more of kim's
relationship with pete but as we know
now they've sent split he's just super
genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and watch tv and
just do nothing
during season one kim was an open book
about their romance explaining how they
first linked up after her snl hosting
debut a few days later i called the
producer at snl and i was like hey do
you have pete's number
and they were like yeah
and i text him i wasn't even thinking
like oh my god i'm gonna be in a
relationship with him i was just
thinking like
heard about this bde need to get out
there like i need to just like
jump start my
i was just basically dtf
the comedian also made a small cameo at
the end of the season appearing off
camera in what else another tmi moment
pete come here you have to meet paxy
paxy has worked with me as audio 14
years from keeping up with the
kardashians she knows everything about
me
she's probably seen my vagina
not more than you but she's but she's
probably seen it kim and pete's love
seemed strong came often giving peaks of
their relationship on social media and
at public events
[Applause]
but fast forward to august and a source
told e.t that love is still there but
the two just worked better as friends
quote there's no drama or anything weird
between them now and we'll likely have
to wait for season 3 to see what cameras
captured when it comes to the split
because as kim says i've always wanted
people to see who i really am
[Music]
you